the carolina panthers are four and three
after a
fairly uh dramatic loss to the san
francisco 49ers
51 not 41 51 to 13 on sunday darren
gantt covered the panthers for years and
has been with pft now for seven seven
years seven plus years darren gant's
been with us he joins us now good
morning daryn how are you
time flies when you're having fun huh
or when you're not i don't know
hopefully you're having fun
i still say that no doubt
this job we have beats the hell out of
working for a living that's for sure and
uh we just get to watch the games
we don't have to actually play in them
there's no injury report for the people
who are covering the games and obviously
that's topic number one for the carolina
panthers who had those four straight
victories darren still waiting for cam
newton we haven't seen him since week
two here we are in week nine it's been
seven weeks since he was on a football
field what's your best understanding as
to when we may see him again if at all
in 2019
i i think if it all is a reasonable
expectation and i think it's going to be
a lot later than a lot of people think i
don't know what happened and i don't
know if some other reporters got
you know fed a line or were doing a
favor for somebody or what but there
were some very over anxious estimations
about when he was going to be back on
the field i mean really from the start
you know people were talking about the
bye week no it was i mean a liz frank's
brain is serious injury and and i i
think even beyond the the mechanics of
the injury itself cam newton's been hurt
for a year and a half or more and in his
fireside chat you know cigar and glass
of wine confessional on his vlog he made
it clear he wasn't going to come back
until he was 100 percent because he's
tired of playing at something less than
a hundred percent which he's been doing
for a very long time so i i think the
desire to get himself completely right
and the panthers desire to not
you know wonder what percentage of them
they're going to get has led them to be
cautious and i think it's still an i was
talking to somebody over there recently
who you know nobody wants to put an
exact date on it but they were talking
about you know the front end of the
speculation would probably be an atlanta
game that's coming up i believe three
weeks four weeks from now i mean they're
kind of looking at the last month of the
season if at all so i i think people are
you know should just kind of get used to
the idea that it's going to be kyle
allen and mostly christian mccaffrey and
they're going to have to ride that
defense as far as they're going to go
yeah it was odd there was a fairly
prominent report a couple of weeks ago
that he was going to be back at practice
last week heading into the 49ers game
and there's been this this this balance
that people are trying to strike do we
want a hundred percent kyle allen or 90
cam newton i mean i agree with you and
every indication i get cam newton's not
going to play until he's 100 and when
he's 100
he clearly is your best option at
quarterback
there's no doubt i mean and they played
that game all last year you know okay is
90 cam better than 100 somebody else
okay what about 80. now we're down to
70. it was like the reverse of the
mountain climber game uh on the price is
right and and every week it got a little
bit worse and a little bit worse and and
it's really in and
it's really imperative for him uh as
much as them to get himself right
because he's going into a contract here
next year and if he's ever going to get
a bite of this 35 40 million a year
quarterback market uh apple then he's
gonna have to get himself well because
right now i don't know who in their
right mind now there are some teams that
aren't in their right mind but who in
their right mind would give that kind of
contract to cam newton because he hasn't
been well on a consistent basis for the
last year and a half now he's played
through injuries
i've said this all the time about the
guy you can't question his toughness he
got hit by a truck and a literal truck
and continued to play football he had
only missed four games you know prior to
shutting him down uh last year with the
shoulder finally now he had played when
he wasn't clearly well so i i think the
guy had been his own worst enemy at
times in the past but i i think he's
realized whether it's turning 30 whether
it's impending contract or whatever but
i think he's kind of come to the
realization that he needs to get himself
right uh for the time beyond uh the 2019
season
yeah and here's the question i have if
he doesn't return at all this year
what will the panthers do next year
because next year is the last year of
his contract it is well below market and
i had always thought this was an up or
out year for cam newton he's either
going to earn another contract that pays
him 30 million per year or maybe more or
they're just gonna move on but if they
never really get a good look at him this
year because he was never healthy this
year what do you do about next year
yeah i would just write it out i mean
honestly and and and if push comes to
shove you've got a franchise tag him at
the end of that process so be it but you
i don't think you can in good conscience
even though david kepper has more
dollars than any single owner in the nfl
i don't think you can justify spending
that many of them on a guy you haven't
seen play so uh i would just write it
out i don't know if he's comfortable
with that but i also don't know that he
has a terrible amount of leverage at the
moment i mean
it's a shame i mean the guy was tough
the guy was successful the guy
did everything right i mean he wears
funny hats and people in charlotte
aren't comfortable with him all the time
but the guy did everything on the field
you could ask him to do and didn't get
in trouble off the field so i'm not sure
what the beef was but
you know to me it's just
you gotta wait and see until he's until
he's well until he shows you he can beat
cam newton and run i you can invest in
him
we're down to the last 30 seconds darren
early on when the panthers lost two home
games to start the season i started to
think maybe ron rivera's got to worry
about things here maybe marty herney
is there a way this goes off the rails
for both of them and they they both
could be on the outside looking in after
the season
a possible i mean if it craters like it
did last year
after a big loss at pittsburgh if they
go and lose seven in a row i think it's
pretty easy to see david tepper being
interested in doing something like that
but you know i i think he also likes
some of the things that's going on here
but so much of it is is quarterback
driven and i mean that's going to be the
central decision and i think everything
stands from there
all right darren great stuff uh we'll
look forward to some prices right
references try to make a plinko
or some other related reference at pft
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports